minha história é uma história marcada
por um momento de desequilíbrio e eu
acredito mesmo que o equilíbrio é super
importante da nossa vida e precisamos
encontrar um caminho da história
então tudo com soul lances mas vou fazer
uma pergunta quem é que tem menos de 25
anos foi o próximo a cair e aqui não faz
a mínima ideia do que quer fazer no
futuro próximo a bauru onde também
estava exatamente diante do céu eu tinha
19 está abaixo da nova e não fazia a
mínima em 2011 desde que a crise da
dívida não ia às aulas não estava nada
foi provado não via praticá-la das
coisas que estava a primeira falta
mostrar que ficava a primeira em casa
até às duas da tarde havia sérias 30
mg/l flona esta dívida não fazia mesmo
idéia do que queria fazer e então a
fazer um trabalho do grupo é prestar uma
nova semente realizar os vários setores
da empresa eo e percebi que o martim de
sá vai mudar muito nos últimos anos e as
marcas hoje em dia querem pessoas
autênticas nos seus anúncios e não um
deus e eu preciso estar aqui qualquer
coisa aqui procura de qualquer coisa é
que eu não posso evitar
eu não fazia a mínima ideia do que
queria fazer e pensar e mesmo alguma
coisa que eu posso eu posso colocar toda
energia então pois muitas noites eram
aquelas noites na câmara que tem
simplesmente pensar alto ea senhora e eu
fiquei até às 23 a minha pensar como é
que eu posso fazer isso como é que eu
posso criar o álcool solucionar esse
problema que há no mercado em uma outra
agência está a fazer pois muitas noites
a pensar se ele começar a saída foi
colado ter tudo no quarto e com o
celular
encontrei uma primeira investida ouro
que foi a minha vó que o dinheiro para
começar e eu era um miúdo que não fazia
a mínima ideia do que estava a fazer
quando o primeiro não sabia o que queria
depois encontrar alguma coisa que queria
fazer e punha em mas não fazia a mínima
ideia do que estava a fazer
houve aumento todos vocês estão muito
mais preparados hoje para montar a
empresa que eu criei do que estava
quando com sair mas eu acredito que nós
não precisamos estar prontos para
começar a e como sair simplesmente com
uma crença
em que eu iria dar uma forma fazer
acontecer
foram 19 anos que não fazia idéia do que
estava a fazer com sono quarto correndo
o estado da avó e dormir no chão dessa
aula todos os dias eram os chutes do
caraças porque porque eu tenho um irmão
mais novo que tem cinco anos e eu dormi
no chão da sala quando a minha mulher
estava lá em casa a dormir quando ela
não dorme eu dormia no quarto dela
quando ela estava a dormir eu tinha que
ser uma imposição da sala ou quarto
estava na empresa com quatro
colaboradores e meu irmão tinha na
altura o pai três anos circulavam todos
os dias o dia sim dia não
às seis da manhã é ver desmate e
comerciais e eu tenho tentado até às
três da manhã com o problema agora por
skype é fazer porcaria do site que nunca
tinha oito equipes irão desenhar tamanho
e foi por isso mesmo muito difícil em
que dormia pouco comia mal não fazia
desporto não fazia a mínima ideia
tentava fazer a única coisa que não
agüenta ver a minha paixão por criar
alguma coisa por serem dependendo fazer
alguma coisa criar uma coisa com as
minhas próprias mãos e começarmos foram
três meses de muito 3 mil fantasias
cinco meses muito muito trabalho agentes
lançaram 16 oficialmente antes foram
sempre presente pé em todos os dias
trabalhados no quarto uma quarta é capaz
de ser três quartos deste paulo e temos
aqui cinco pessoas a trabalhar e nós
recebíamos pessoas todos os dias para
falarmos com elas para explicar mas o
que era sogra recebemos a textura do
nosso território para um quarto
quero jogar dentro de casa com o pai
quando foi viver com elas do iphone não
tem espaço pra mim
estávamos lá a trabalhar todos todos os
dias trabalhar em le mans depois depois
de muita luta muito sofrimento muita
aprendizagem que eu tentei fazer as
coisas acontecerem como a equipa se viu
sua seleção no dia 7 de setembro de 2014
e quando lançamos o som dele eu era
começamos sobre o anúncio da nota que eu
pensava
isso vai ser inacreditável nunca me
investigar e vai ser incrível exploração
no ar no dia a seguir vamos ter os media
atrás de nós vem aqui bater à porta
porque documentário o que aconteceu e
vamos ter os clientes a bater na porta e
enviar um e mail dizendo nós queremos
trabalhar convosco e toda a gente vai
comentar em passado uma semana vai
investir us 20 mil likes no facebook e
nós lançamos a sua mercê
temos 2 mil eleitores e nada aconteceu
lá aconteceu estamos nós com imensas
produtivas fizemos um jantar da equipe
fomos ao prédio da peixaria estavam
centésimos pai no espaço de um dia
tivermos pai 1.500 likes em
retrospectiva fx é bom mas na altura
tinha uma missão tão grande uma
expectativa é tão grande que é
impossível simplesmente conseguir fazer
um metro essa expectativa e quando temos
uma expectativa grande dias pdt beto
fraudada
há uma coisa que nos acontece
emocionalmente que nós fizemos muito mas
muito frustrados e foi isso que
aconteceu
eu nada comecei a sentir os meus sonhos
é ir em um rio de 19 anos alto gasto em
2010 e energia é conseguir pôr toda a
gente a shout e conseguiu para a roça
feliz por um mito que começou a virar si
próprio e não comecei a pensar surgir um
que no pensamento na cabeça que foi
outra mas eu falei não tem a mínima
hipótese não tinha passado o dia tem
avançado
vou fazer o que eu vou fazer vou ficar
ver a minha avó que as pessoas vão
pensar que eu não vou conseguir fazer e
depois ainda tem que voltar à faculdade
hoje já não posso voltar a falar o que
eu vou fazer a minha vida e este
pensamento não sei se vocês que já
alguma vez tiveram este pensamento
entramos num looping negativo na área
começa uma pequena cozinha que se
transforma em um enorme abismo em que
nós temos na merda mas oito minutos e eu
e um mito que não tenha qualquer tipo de
presença a liderar qualquer tipo de
experiência lidar com com muita opção
com o secretário emocionalmente e sonha
retrospectiva eu consigo perceber isso
eu comecei simplesmente não acreditar
que conseguirá fazer sombra a acontecer
e lembro me perfeitamente tv estava numa
reunião da equipa
tínhamos lançado há cerca de dois três
dias é mesmo estava constantemente
teixeira e temos a indústria estava no
caminho da equipa e estamos a falar que
eu estava me sentir realmente não sei
porque começou a se apoderar nenhuma
sensação de medo e de ansiedade e
nervosismo fazer uma pergunta quem é que
já presenciou
ela já teve a ansiedade e tenha coragem
de admitir
fiz olha mantenha os braços no ar e
olhem a vossa volta à nossa volta só
possível em que é uma coisa que todos
nós já sentimos que é importante
falarmos sobre isso quanto mais nós não
falamos sobre as coisas que nos torna
mais humanos mais nós acreditamos que
estamos sozinhos
todos nós e não pela nossa vida já se
internou na cidade eu nunca tinha
sentido uma certa o extremo está vendo
aquela sala no quarto 3416 palco estavam
todos sentados em círculo internet e eu
nada conseguia sentir meu coração bater
mais depressa e com mais força em função
do vírus em a cabeça conseguem entrar em
suas frios estava ao mesmo tempo com
suores frios pelo corpo todo e com
imenso calor como parecia que ia
explodir a crescer e com isso obter
forte é bater forte
esse mesmo time saltar pela boca e eu
tava ali e há uma coisa muito
interessante sobre um livro é como
lidera tem de mostrar segurança mesmo
que não esteja seguro é como as
primeiras nós temos no avião o piloto o
comandante diz que vai ver tudo em
reconhecemos todos o que vai acontecer
olha o sport quer o avião estava capotar
água na área e não posso perder a
votação que decidirá a água tem que
fazer essa situação nós não estamos
vendendo muita incerteza nem fazia a
mínima ideia do que acontecer e se não
trouxesse certeza aquela sala eu não
estar surgindo uma empresa de segurança
mas eu não estava seguro eu estava
altamente senhor eu queria sempre me
desculpa eu tive que sair do quadro eu
já vim tirar alguma coisa tomar alguma
coisa estava mesmo ao ac diretos e be
falei com a equipe volta de imóvel que
será referência tirar uma semana de
férias porque trabalhei muito tempo
muito cansado estou energética e menos
emocional - deputado admite que existe
foi muito complicado também pra mim
compreender aquela suportar parte
fighter frente nada mal acontece e
acordamos todos os dias às cinco e meia
da manhã
aproveite para fazer desporto pedindo
para agradar a muita coisa que se chama
o empreendedor fará no fim do dia somos
todos humanos e na altura estava a ter
dificuldade em reconhecer que eu também
era um ano e ter essa semana a diferença
e continua durante a semana de férias é
sentir essas tiradas interesse pessoal
se tinha uma rocha gigante nos ombros e
que nada conseguia quebrar mas com o
tempo fui uma semana após treinar por
causa da minha mãe e fui para uma
mensagem uma mensagem aqui com os meus
amigos rocha ativa em casa sem fazer
nada a ver séries já não via há meses
tive com calma e eu percebi que eu não
queria estar naquela fita um louco não
podia estar simplesmente é trabalhar
trabalhar e conhecer pessoas atalanta
fazer site fazer logo a fazer tudo e
mais alguma coisa não podia tirar tempo
pra mim tá manhã e um pensamento de ter
um crescimento que foi me dera tem
trazer muita segurança como a zara é um
ambiente não existe certeza
absolutamente nenhuma
nós temos mesmo de conseguir pôr as
pessoas está tudo tranqüilo e nós temos
que ser é rocha o ix30 essas pessoas que
garante que nada vai acontecer
e para nós conseguirmos alguma vez
liderar os outros nós conseguiremos
tirar essa pedra para conseguir essa
pessoa pois os outros pra cima quando
estão em baixa nós conseguimos lembrar
os outros nós temos que nos lembrar a
nossa própria imagem
e aí bateu eu nunca vou conseguir
liderar esta equipa que na altura não só
quatro pessoas serão livrar a minha
própria primário e eu não posso lembrar
a minha própria primeiro senão 10 m em
primeiro lugar ele te foi das minhas
missões mais importantes os outros
quatro anos de empreendedorismo que é
pra nós de facto liderada pela equipa
nós temos que tratar o macho porque nós
tivemos constantemente vara militar e
dar lhe dar e garante que os outros
também há críticas que isso não
acontecer temos de dar tudo nós nós
eventualmente que vão ficar vazias
nós temos que ser também temos que
trazer coisas para nós
eu não trouxe lhe se eu quero fazer um
bom trabalho e eu tenho que passar tempo
com os meus amigos por ser um passatempo
com os meus amigos vamos sentir
emocionalmente brasil se não tiver
conectado no dia d contra 11 e vamos
sentir emocionalmente frágil e para
fazer um sonho e trabalho eu chego lá
todos os dias entre gado
eu tenho que estar bem eu tenho que
estar feliz e tenho que estar contente e
nós não estamos felizes por termos a
selecção e se vocês tenham estudado
certeza que já passaram pelos movimentos
de terra
então a estudar estudar e estudar a
história e do nada vocês são mais sérias
agrada-nos rico da faculdade nesse
momento eu não conseguir eu era um livro
que deve nem ser gravadas por tudo e
mais alguma coisa estava constantemente
rir e se a gente não conseguir tava
sendo um sério motivo quer dizer um rio
nós precisamos dessas informações a
nossa vida e nós não vamos fazer um bom
trabalho estivemos mal das nossas
posições nós fizemos um bom trabalho o
objetivo e somos líderes e cremes
trabalhar procurando trabalhar e
queremos entregar mesmo um bom trabalho
nós temos que pôr as nossas funções
primárias porque senão vamos ter um
emocional muito frágil e não vamos
entregar e pra nós por nossas relações
para nós estarmos bem de nossas funções
nós precisamos de estar em um sinal
muito ruim porque nós tivemos frustrado
e chateado e zangadas sempre as nossas
forças vão sofrer com isso
esse nosso arroz foi com isso nosso
trabalho vai sofrer com isso estaremos
em um sinal muito bem grande news que
também estamos felizes estamos relaxados
que estamos bem dispostos que estamos
brincando não estamos calmas
estamos tranquilos é quase mais
importantes que a mas nós estamos bem
emocionalmente nós precisamos estar
energeticamente em tamanho não dormir de
banho e nós nos alimentarmos bem só não
fizemos porque era o que estava
acontecendo a autora é muito fácil noche
energeticamente e vai ser urgentemente
foram as baixas emissões vão sentir
porque vai de bob nosso corpo e nossa
mente tão intrinsecamente ligados às
nossas emoções sentem mal
nós temos com marrocos nós tivemos com
as emoções e as nossas relações
vamos cobrar as nossas posições setembro
o nosso trabalho quebra e por isso é
mesmo mesmo importante eu quero
partilhar este momento de desequilíbrio
emocional e energético psicológico eu
tive até um metro para que vocês não
tenham que passar pelo mesmo porque se
vocês estão neste momento têm menos de
25 anos e querem sirene não sabe o que
quer fazer e querem se e fazer com que
você vir a acontecer como vocês querem
fazer acontecer
se vocês realmente querem ir para uma
vida incrível
vocês têm mesmo por vós próprios
primeiro porque se você chorar em vão
sentir mesmo
eventualmente brasil eu estou partilhar
esta história aqui com vocês para que
vocês não tenham que passar por esse
sofrimento que o passageiro e pronto e
se sair da sala você é uma semana de
férias 15 as mensagens que foram os
amigos vi séries
voltei já mais calma ainda com o
pensamento que eu falei na altura a
minha crença não vou falar que não tem a
mínima hipótese mas passar dois ou três
dias de voltar porque temos um maiô de
um cliente e uma vazia
fred obrigado pelo teu irmão gostei mais
do que vocês fazem
temos um entendimento e voltem começar a
trabalhar convosco e viu nada
toda essa montanha que eu tinha toda a
carga que eu tinha em cima de mim mas
apareceu do nada o frança do nada eu
percebi talvez eu consiga mesmo fazer
acontecer e desde aí que eu penso sempre
que todos os dias entre a hora que
entrar entre as 9 milhões e também é
sempre que eu entro na sombra eu estou
lá pra ferver
eu estou lá para garantir que elas fazer
o melhor trabalho possível estou lá para
garantir que elas têm maior facilidade
em fazer o melhor trabalho possível
um livro era uma pessoa que serve quem
se viu servir à sua causa
qualquer lei todos nós vamos rever nossa
vida nós temos um apreço servir nós
temos lá pra entregar e por isso eu
todos os dias entram no escritório e
pensei estou aqui para dar o meu melhor
me enfrente todas as pessoas fazem o
melhor trabalho possível para ter para
que organize um crash coletivamente eu
tenho que chegar lá com muito pra eu
todo dia e tenho que ir lá e tem que ter
em mesmo horário tem que estar
emocionalmente o time tem que estar
incrivelmente energeticamente tenho que
ter as minhas funções ou não tá eu não
posso não ter passado tempo com minha
namorada não possam ter passado tempo
com minha família
não posso não ter passado tempo com os
meus amigos não posso não ter evitado
não posso não ter dormido bem não posso
não ter feito de couro e por isso todos
os dias e o primeiro piso e o primeiro
sempre as minhas funções das missões e
energia para que esteja em embu em
abundância porque se eu estiver em
abundância e se estiver muito trabalho
vou lá chegar e conseguir acrescentar e
esta é a história que quer partilhar com
vocês
obrigado
[Aplausos]